she might be a little on the sexual side
Oh oh my goodness oh my you're gonna see
another cartoon I don't know I do not
want to see any more cartoons I want to
watch a cartoon I don't want to watch
some sort of sexist racist propaganda as
this one's just a love story just a guy
in a lady that's bad they even that's
bad and another guy and they're having a
good time I mean that's not good this is
not yet trust me I brought your ID okay
first of all this armrest is kind of a
barrier and if you could just least
respect like the halfway point or at
least not cross over into my area good
god play just just watch this one yeah
okay
special it's called in my Oldsmobile oh
no this is gonna be weird
oh my Mario's will be I'm sorry oh so
cold yeah part of this applies for
studios the Fleischer brothers this was
it a song back in 1905 and it was kind
of sexy so now yeah you do that plays
yeah
what even the clock is trying to be yeah
so back that clock for a very offensive
look she's got good luck yeah yeah I
mean all I want to do is see a lady bit
okay so she's got issues - yeah well
ladies head were a lot of dress
inspector so she closed that just
besides a crack and he can't get over he
can't even believe what he's doing
that's how bad yeah right exactly yeah
he's like what is this shame okay my
girls have our troubles
ah
yeah what she shoutout for but all of us
that was the point of the mousetrap I
guess it makes your butt look bigger and
so he's gonna miss out on date he is
supposed to be there no no he's not he's
just a pervert who is just a guy broke
through her door okay great
lock that up he's got a key yep that he
eats all right that's a bad sign that's
when a dude breaks in your room and eats
a key it's definitely time to hit the
last one on 911 yeah but now he's
staring in here cuz he what is happening
he's like just he's like a rapist
there's like comfort riding a car lady
she might be a little on the sexual
assault whoa oh oh my goodness oh my
what is happening down if the dude shows
up and gives you peppermint you don't
eat it oh yeah please hug her oh wait so
she was turned on by the Oldsmobile nope
no she doesn't want him okay I get ya
he's been walking turn off but it's
moustaches cool
I don't like that when trusted she's
saying she'd be killed yeah I mean a
rhymin be nice but whatever I guess
she's pissed
of course gotta get that in and then
here's I think this is her fella that's
her fella yeah oh he's got ya buddy
buddy there's a hole yeah so obviously
it's locked
yeah but man it's locked just enter well
yeah there we go
oh so this guy's real wimpy or - he's on
salvia right they turn him in the stairs
what
yay so these guys invented the white dot
aren't songs oh really yeah is that
what's about to happen
yeah I'm Nydia white dotted yeah what
she's got a big old can and he's trying
to get her in there yep this is how cars
work all she said yes to was a ride and
he immediately pulled up her skirt and
now you're going this getting her away
from a rapist don't forget oh my
goodness
[Music]
so she steers and he's like hey you're
gonna marry me now I'm away with me
Lucille
[Music]
[Applause]
hard hey you see audience singing to
this before the movie yeah oh yeah right
before the picture show and this guy's a
robber
what does anybody know we're notes aloud
from the network were they allowed to go
like hey it's insane three-quarters of
the way through stop it's just like the
journey for an ending to a story that
doesn't exist it's fine let's do it I
burnout you man and why you may have sex
with the car man and wife still rings
true
boom boys no different
Oh
that was great that's a true love story
yeah I met my wife through it almost no
I know no I was gonna say I remember you
saying how you met her you put her in an
Oldsmobile and then you left and then
drove to a chapel when we box now you're
boxing partner cuz we're in love I mean
it kind of just makes me think that
maybe commercials are good because when
you see them now you get it you're like
oh yeah this is for a hot pocket very
clear every time I show you what is I
feel weird yeah as you should this is
weird it's a weird situation turns out
that everything back then was bad yeah
and now - so whatever let's just watch
another goddamn cartoon thank you
you